[Música]
num futuro muito próximo
as empresas desonestas vão desaparecer
do mercado
a primeira vez que eu falei isso pra
minha esposa que está ali ela virou pra
mim e falou daniel você é muito ingênua
eu acredito em penedo as esperança dela
e de muitos de vocês que pensam a
entendem com descrença essa frase de
fato a gente vive um capitalismo
selvagem onde muitas empresas a tam em
escândalos de corrupção de fraude nós
estamos acostumados a ver isso nos
noticiários no dia a dia quando as
empresas nós conhecemos estão envolvidas
em escândalos de corrupção de fraude e
lavagem de dinheiro
mas não só isso que degradam o meio
ambiente não tem iniciativas de
sustentabilidade não pensa nas próximas
gerações
empresas que utilizam exploram
mão-de-obra infantil o trabalho escravo
que fazem testes cruéis em animais que
não tratam bem seus colaboradores e não
tem relações positivas com seus clientes
quais são os valores que nós acreditamos
para a construção de um mercado
consciente já que o capitalismo existe
esses são valores que nós precisamos
entender abraçá los para que a gente
possa criar um mercado consciente e
gerar então empresas honestas e íntegras
e éticas e as empresas que não se
adaptarem a essa realidade elas vão
desaparecer do mercado
eu quero trazer que três motivos a
didáticos pelos quais eu acredito nisso
o primeiro é que o mercado age com base
em confiança
quero trazer que senhoras e senhores
adam smith o pai da economia que
ensinava que a confiança é a base do
capitalismo
se a gente tirar a confiança ea verdade
das relações comerciais
o capitalismo desaba um exemplo são as
relações de troca entre papel moeda
embora esse papel e mesmo os bits
cartão de crédito não tem nenhum valor
em si eles representam o valor ea gente
acredita nisso
se a gente tirar a confiança nas
relações comerciais o capitalismo desaba
e é por isso que várias grandes empresas
e mesmo alguns governos começaram a
fazer a pesquisa reputacionais a para
selecionar fornecedores que tenham
posicionamento de mercado ético e
íntegro isso se chama do dirigente
integridade ou seja o próprio mercado
trata de scut as empresas desonestas
é por isso que eu acredito que as
empresas desonestas daquelas que não são
integrantes vão desaparecer do mercado
o segundo motivo é que a gente vive uma
mudança de era a com uma geração que é a
consumidor consciente e que eu quero
fazer um rápido com isso a quantos de
vocês se tiverem uma marca de chocolate
de uma empresa que vocês sabem que é
honesta a e uma marca de chocolate que
existem dificuldades o que pairam
dúvidas sobre a honestidade de dessa
empresa quantos de vocês comprariam
definitivamente chocolate da marca que a
unesco mais ou menos 56%
recentemente foi feita uma pesquisa no
brasil que mostrou que o brasileiro de
aumento de uma maneira geral 56% deles
preferem comprar uma é de marcas que têm
uma reputação de integridade e
honestidade
a minha família mesmo não compra mais
chocolate de uma série de indústrias
brasileiras por que paira sobre elas a
dúvida se eles utilizam ou não mão de
obra infantil na produção de cacau na
áfrica
o mais importante é que hoje as nossas
gerações y e z que já estão no mercado
representam 70 milhões de pessoas somos
nós
quarenta e seis por cento quase metade
da população economicamente ativa
a mesma pesquisa que mostrou que 56% dos
brasileiros compram com base no
posicionamento de mercado de ética
quando o recorte é feito para as
gerações y e z
ela sobe para 60%
o que significa que nós somos hoje o
público consumidor
a fatia de mercado maior que existe no
mundo as gerações y e z já ditam a como
será o posicionamento de mercado das
novas empresas
é por isso que acredito que nós como
consumidores conscientes podemos
escamotear as empresas que são
desonestos e que não são integradas para
isso obviamente nós precisamos fazer um
grande pacto social em prol de um
consumo consciente
além disso nós buscamos não mais
transações comerciais a em que a gente
dá dinheiro recebe um produto por mais
que ele seja bom
a nós queremos relações com as empresas
já foi dito aqui há um exemplo que eu
quero deixar o exemplo da amazon
recentemente eu comprei um produto na
amazon que era pra chegar no dia 1º de
abril no dia 2 de abril o produto não
chegou eu reclamei
eles me disseram senhor desculpa nós
vamos mandar um novo produto naquele
mesmo dia o produto chegou e aí eu
voltei a conversar com a amazon
e aí eu falei ela não precisa mais
mandar o produto
o produto que era para chegar ontem
chegou agora e eles nos disseram a gente
já mandou o produto pode fazer com ele o
que vocês quiserem essa é uma forma a
gente pedir desculpa e demonstrar o
nosso caráter e integridade de boa fé
com os nossos clientes
essas são as empresas do futuro são
essas empresas que vão perdurar
assim como as empresas desonestas elas
vão ser escanteado no mercado
o terceiro argumento é que a geração y e
z
a gente não é somente a maior fatia de
consumidor do mundo a gente também é
força de trabalho
existe uma pesquisa que mostra que em
dez anos nós vamos ter 75% de toda a
força de trabalho do mundo e nós
diferentemente das gerações que nos
antecederam
não busca só dinheiro nem só
estabilidade e segurança no emprego a
gente quer viver e trabalhar por popó
propósitos
a gente quer trabalhar empresas éticas e
integrava nestas empresas que contribuem
com o meio ambiente que fazem o bem para
a comunidade onde estão inseridas que
tem um propósito maior do que só vender
empresas que querem continuar com coisas
boas vão impedir que algumas coisas
ótimas
apareçam são essas empresas que a
geração y e z que trabalhar significa
que nós não só
só podemos trabalhar empresas éticas e
honestas
porque nós queremos a a entender o nosso
propósito nelas como a gente também vai
fazer delas empresas mais justas e mais
honestas
eu quero trazer aqui pra exemplifica
isso a pirâmide de maslow essa é uma
pirâmide que mostra as necessidades dos
seres humanos desde as mais básicas como
fisiológico segurança social até outras
necessidades e de uma maneira geral nós
das gerações y e z da classe média
global
já conseguimos alcançar por parte dessas
necessidades
e hoje nós temos novas necessidades
especialmente reconhecimento e
auto-realização ea gente entende que a
gente consegue alcançar isso por meio do
trabalho o que significa que nós somos
não só o poder a de consumidor mas
também uma força de trabalho que vai
scut as empresas desonestas e como as
empresas se adaptam a esta nova
realidade elas vão necessariamente fale
as desonestas
pode ser que sim pode ser que não mas as
empresas que não falei em vão precisar
se adaptar e a solução para esse dilema
compliance comparece uma palavra pequena
inglesa mas que tem um representativo
muito forte por trás dela significa que
todas as empresas que querem pensar a
longo prazo precisam institucionalizar
políticas ferramentas e metodologias
para que elas continuem abraçando
aqueles valores e continua em 13o nestas
além disso no meio de tantos empregos
que estão acabando
eis um emprego novo para vocês que são
estudantes direito engenharia filosofia
como tantos outros podem se tornar
compreensível office certamente será o
emprego do futuro e esse emprego é o
grande guardião da integridade e da
ética nas empresas
por fim eu realmente acredito que as
empresas honestas vão acabar e isso é
tanto um prognóstico quanto o manifesto
é um prognóstico que olha para o futuro
e eu tenho certeza de que
empresas que não são integradas não vão
permanecer no mercado mas também é um
programa mas também o manifesto porque
eu acredito que nós precisamos nos
mobilizar para que isso aconteça tanto
como um público consumidor consciente
como uma força de trabalho engajado
se a gente fizer isso a gente vai
contribuir para uma geração de valor
geração de riqueza por meio das empresas
sem abrir mão dos valores que nos tornam
seres humanos
obrigado
[Aplausos]